sur le perron se produit dopant par qui
le scandale est arrivé
accepte finalement de témoigner
américain à monsieur bonsoir une
collision entre deux avions cet après
midi au large de quiberon dans le
morbihan a fait 15 morts pilote
occupants des deux appareils ont été
tués il n'y aa priori aucun survivant
lundi deux avions avec 13 personnes à
son bord assurer une liaison régulière
entre lyon et l'aéroport de lorient
l'autre appareil était un des avions de
l'aéro club de vannes dans le morbihan
tirer kurde s'est très vite chacun 10
900 qui assurait la ligne lyon lorient
pour la compagnie franche et us mais
avant d'arriver à destination
le commandant de bord a demandé la tour
de contrôle de lorient de s'écarter de
sa route pour survoler la baie de
quiberon n'était alors 15h50 le nord où
l ex paquebot france entrait dans la
paix c'est probablement pour survoler le
navire que l'avion s'est dérouté et
c'est à ce moment là qu'il a percuté un
cessna 199 habite une deux personnes à
bord il y avait plusieurs avions de
tourisme au dessus du bateau un
photographe était dans l'un de ses
avions dans le premier simple le procès
juste et est en train de le biais du
théâtre mon vélo j'ai vu s'écraser
justement subit donc
là vu la carlingue son côté solo flanque
un survivant côté personne rien second
plan et le talent elle avait déjà parti
paris font le bilan est actuellement de
15 morts oui et donc l'appareil
visiblement est tombés les deux
appareils sont tombés autour du paquebot
norwegian siens france qui est
actuellement dans cette région est l'un
des avions l'avion qui venait de lyon
ses terres on vous l'a dit détourné pour
aller admirer le bateau qui se trouve
donc actuellement au large de quiberon
après la folle journée hier le tour de
france cycliste est reparti quinqua
d'aix les bains en direction de
neuchâtel en suisse et ce malgré la
défection de plusieurs équipes notamment
les espagnols et la poursuite des
interrogatoires de garde à vue pour des
directeurs sportifs et l'actuel tenant
du grand prix de la montagne d'aliens
massy qui ce soir est toujours en garde
à vue pour ce qui concerne l'étape du
jour c'est le belge tom fils qui l'a
emporté au sprint langue trop alain
points après les confiner les basses ce
matin au départ au chant
on murmure et la rumeur redémarre avis
il coureur italien hésite à repartir et
se consultent frais l'abandon des
équipes espagnoles
certains disent tout haut ce que les
autres pensent tout bas les équipes
françaises ont décidé de se remettre en
selle parfois à contre coeur certains
ont bien envie d'imiter laurent jalabert
ils seront donc sans toi j'ai lancé un
couteau on put aimé dessiner et les
nappes aujourd'hui le blond le tour a
donc de grandes chances d'aller au bout
et sur la route de neuchâtel les
coureurs ne traîne pas après 45 km de
course catherine s'échappent les
français des biens vasseur et mangeant
élite asnières donati une échappée
sérieuse un peloton vigilant ça
une étape classique le public a
d'ailleurs clairement choisi son camp
celui des coureurs qui ont décidé de
faire le spectacle
218 kilomètres au compteur les coiffer
la toile
lizotte de tête accusent jusqu'à six
minutes d'avancé c'était insuffisant le
poteau revenus des sprinteurs ont
retrouvé le plaisir que sprinter tom
steels gp de belgique en profite pour
remporter sa troisième étape une étape
qui se déroule normalement
c'est un soulagement pour les
organisateurs le certains coureurs
ici ça parce que ça me faisait
énormément mal c'est peut-être mon
dernier tour ma carrière tous les jouets
en bois le dernier tour mais il était
dit que ce tour 81,18 ne vivrai jamais
une journée ordinaire qui s'offriront
refuse d'enfiler le maillot de meilleur
grimpeur
un maillot qu'il portait hier encore son
coéquipier russell simmons l'heure
actuelle toujours en garde à vue
parmi les couloirs qui n'ont pas repris
le départ ce matin des décisions
individuelles comme celles de luc
leblanc le français mais aussi on viens
de vous le dire des absences
involontaires comme celles d'el italien
rodolfo massy l'une des vedettes de ce
tour de france n'est pas magnifique
puisqu'il portait le maillot à pois
rouges celui du meilleur grimpeur
d'après les indiscrétions on a appris
que des produits suspects des
corticoïdes ont été découverts dans sa
chambre à chambé alexandre kara est
nathalie pas de discours mais un geste
simple signe de protestation ce soit
christophe rinero a refusé de porter le
maillot à pois du meilleur grimpeur
il ya encore 24 heures / hayots était
celui de rodolfo massy mais ce matin me
coureurs italiens n'étaient pas sur la
ligne de départ
placé en garde à vue par les enquêteurs
les corticoïdes aurait été découvert
dans la chambre du coureur dans l'équipe
casino on n'a pas le moral
des portiques wheels et je suis vous
ayez une mauvaise tendinite quelque
chose n'importe qui doit en prendre donc
il faut arrêter de dire que c'est un
gris parce que c'est faux donc il faut
arrêter la suspicion surtout dans ce cas
là ben moi j'ai de la vitamine c je vais
l'acheter à l'eau parce que peut être un
dealer ce matin dans l'équipe casino
il y un vélo sans titulaire numéro 68 ne
prendra pas le départ pour deux
formations n'a pas été libéré c'est la
première fois que la justice empêche un
coureur de rejoindre le tour défense
savoir former les gens qui n'ont pas
envie d'aller en sachant que marat
danton lavenu le directeur sportif a lui
aussi été entendu par la police hier
soir avant d'être relâchés
c'est sur la ligne d'arrivée qu'il
apprend et des produits interdits aurait
été trouvé en possession d'hormones
formation c'est une partisane parce
qu'il est allergique hangar 6 et des
produits dopants
maintenant pour transformer le texte
nous on laisse création interne et on
prendra des décisions
et c'est vrai sur le tour le discours a
changé
après le temps de la protestation pure
et simple on s'accommode de la situation
les choses là mais je ne porterais où
tout est formel le plus précieux si
d'aller jusqu'au bout du tour comme si
l'on pouvait encore sauver les
apparences
malgré les protestations des coureurs et
de la direction du tour de france toute
une série de perquisitions
d'interrogatoires ont pu mieux la nuit
dernière dont dans les hôtels de
plusieurs équipes de la ville étape
librement cette fois ci les choses se
sont mieux passées entre policiers
coureurs pour la justice ces différentes
opérations mettent en lumière toute une
feuille de comportement plus ou moins
suspect dans plusieurs week
parce qu'elle nous c'est bon alors en
haut de son mât ci portait jusqu'à
maintenant le maillot à pois
celui du meilleur grimpeur de ce tour de
france mais d'hier dans sa chambre à
l'hôtel de son équipe
casino des corticoïdes dérivés de
cortisone interdits ont été retrouvés
par les policiers
des policiers qu'ils soupçonnaient déjà
le coureur italien de participer à un
réseau de dopage au dos le format ci est
toujours à l'hôtel de police
même sort pour nicolas terre à dos le
médecin de l'équipe espagnole
on sait ses avocats vers 17 heures n'ont
pu que constater ma prolongation de sa
garde à vue
la police continuait mais il y a un bon
dossier des éléments
et qu'il est normal il s'explique ce
furent des éléments bien précis car les
enquêteurs ont fait d'autres trouvailles
dans le camion des ondes sur plusieurs
produits dopants et des fioles sans
étiquette dont le contenu est en cours
d'analysé
le juge d'instruction lillois patrick
qu'elle voulait aller vite pour avancer
dans ce dossier un dossier que l'on
appelait festina jusqu'à présent mais
que la justice préfère appeler
maintenant le dossier tour de france
tant il s'étend à d'autres équipes
autant perdre ce soir on a le sentiment
ulissi que les policiers sont en train
de dérouler une pelote de laine
interrogatoire après l'autre mais quand
on cause des nouvelles équipes
ouais l'expression est juste
effectivement l'impression que jusqu'il
à lille à une pelote dans les mains il a
déroulé un fils aujourd'hui utile et il
étire sur ce fil alors on peut rappeler
le point départ une voiture de soigneur
festina rempli produits dopants ensuite
l'interpellation du directeur sportif de
l'équipe qui passe des aveux et dans ses
aveux il parle un système dopage
généralisé depuis 1993 ans qu'on fait
les enquêteurs
non seulement ils sont intéressés aux
coureurs actuels de l'équipe festina
mais se remonter aux anciens coureurs
ceux qui couraient en 93 94 95 et qui
court aujourd'hui dans d'autres équipes
c'est ça qui permet aux enquêteurs de
lille aujourd'hui d'arriver à l'équipe
en c1 équipe casino est l'équipe
française des jeux et on a pris tout à
l'heure que ce juste hilali a obtenu
l'autorisation de la part du parquet
d'élargir son enquête bien au delà de la
sphère testing as à d'autres équipes on
n'est peut-être pas au bout du fil
alors question essentielle aussi claude
les policiers ont ils fait des
découvertes écouter un communiqué du
parquet
avec des termes très précis on parle de
produits dopants interdits saisis dans
un camion de l'équipe ondes c'est avec
des fioles sans étiquette qui sont en
cours d'analysé
en plus quand par le produits dopants
interdits et pour l'équipe casino on
l'entend du dans la chambre du coureur
rodolfo massy des corticoïdes
il ya un petit peu polémique ce soir
c'est effectivement du produit interdit
c'est des produits qu'on peut prendre
sous certaines conditions
quand on est malade mais a semblé il
faut des ordonnances et à parements de
province il a du mal à trouver les
ordonnances pas c'est pourquoi ce soir
le médecin de l'équipe c est le coureur
italien rodolfo vinci sont toujours en
garde à vue ici au commissariat chambéry
et il devrait prochainement transféré à
lille très bientôt
merci à gauche ce soir encore conscient
de la suspicion qui plane sur le tour de
france cycliste qui peut le remettre en
cause à terme le premier dans la société
du tour de france jean paul kenny
annonce très rapidement une table ronde
dont il faudra sortir ni qui en ayant
prouvé la solution politique
la société du tour de france as tu as
toujours été à la pointe du combat
contre le dopage
mais personne ne peut dire rien lui
reprocher dans ce domaine là nous avons
été les premiers à
pratique et les les contrôles sanguins
par exemple qui sont une émanation des
découvreurs fenix et sen systèmes en
janvier mignot est en était le leader ce
que nous allons faire d'abord nous
allons arriver à paris si l'on est
l'état des lieux et ensuite comme je lé
proposés il ya déjà une quinzaine de
jours sous l'égide de l'union cycliste
internationale il nous va unir toutes
les compos nous tous les composants du
sport city cement au plus haut niveau
c'est à dire les corps et les
organisateurs les médecins les officiels
le gérant d'espoir dans une pièce dont
je pense qu'elle doit être fermé ainsi
que les fenêtres certains en sortiront
avec un oeil au beurre noir voire deux
n'est ayant construit parce qu'il faut
aller jusqu'au fond des choses pour
reconstruire et repartir sur des bases
absolument nouvelle donc dans pas mal de
domaines il faut le savoir
donc quand la déclaration de jean-claude
qui vit le produit dopant en vedette
entre guillemets si je puis dire depuis
le début de ces affaires de dopage c'est
le pays où un produit qui agit sur le
sens pour améliorer les performances
mais dont les effets secondaires met en
danger voire la santé voir la vie des
champions ce traitement est le dernier
en date le plus sophistiqué jusqu'à
présent indécelable nous dit on lors des
contrôles routiers tard et je vous
demande de me rendre dans les minutes
pour sheila janyk s'est faite il ya plus
d'un an en plein tour d'italie l'union
cycliste internationale inaugurait des
tests sanguins pour les coureurs
premières équipes contrôlées au petit
matin
festina le sang prélevé contenu utile de
le paix au impossible de le dire avec
cette machine
elle permet simplement de repérer un
temps trop riches en globules rouges
s'il convainc les prix on ne parle pas
de dopage niveau champions juste niveau
n'arrête travail
raisons de santé l'arme peut sembler
dérisoire car le p o
en tout depuis bientôt dix ans le coton
professionnels au début des années 90 ce
produit qui permet d'augmenter le nombre
de globules rouges tant qu accroître les
performances a fait son apparition avec
des coureurs italiens
ancien médecin de l'équipe le dr armand
mégret a quitté le milieu cycliste
lorsque le bo s'est généralisé coureurs
avec comme entraîneur des médecins et ça
a été la rive qui a commis très parce
que vous faites de maîtrise est devenu
entraîneur et quand un médecin nous
entraîne un risque à une préparation
logique les autres coureurs qui vont
n'utilisez pas le pe s'apercevait qu'il
y avait deux courses et avait su
attaquer ce seront et petit à petit il
ya eu le mimétisme avec le pays
le dopage devient organise d'entraidé a
fini sa carrière il ya deux ans dans
l'équipe italienne a qui ont duré
proposé dans mon époque c'était bon dans
l'équipe rouge et r on avait un médecin
qui quitteraient qui lui vraiment et
contraint ses produits prohibés à
contenir une autre médecin qui était pas
trop connu du milieu qui lui a lu il
prêchait pour ça
ces femmes aux produits on a voulu
m'emmener chez lui et on sait le
directeur sportif de l'équipe radio
ritter sportif médias qui ne valait
discuter avec intel voir si peu à manier
quelques améliorations au programme
on appelle ça un programme pour lutter
contre ces programmes est détecté le
préau lui cia quand est il ya deux ans
une expérience un peu avant le porte en
suisse toutes les équipes ont reçu le
document
il proposait aux volontaires une analyse
sanguine approfondi cette fois 14 par
admettre différentes devait être prise
en cours l'anonymat est garanti
il n'y avait aucune sanction à craindre
pourtant plus de la moitié des coureurs
a refusé d'aider les scientifiques
de moyens de lutter grâce à des produits
de plus en plus sophistiqués les
contrôles antidopage se sont révélés de
bien faibles remparts un paradoxe
lorsque certains médecins assurent que
les effets de l'eau peuvent se voir à
l'oeil nu
nous ne regardons pas les couronnes il
fait un unique et puis tu rictus mais je
trouve bien deux dernières philosophie
lucciardi meute est sur le vélo à
l'écart maximal on sait que si cela est
mal maintenant je vois plus beaucoup de
couloirs créneau c'est tout et pas plus
de cette année à l'occasion des
différentes garde à vue des coureurs de
l'équipe festina ou encore de l'équipe
hollandaise tvm les champions étaient
souvenez-vous soumis à un test sans
liens et à celui de la mèche de cheveux
sur laquelle relativement longtemps
après la prise d'un produit dopant on
peut encore mieux déceler et bien ses
cheveux sont confiés à des laboratoires
spécialisés comme celui de strasbourg
reportage mais christine beauce patrick
mathé dans le laboratoire de toxicologie
et de médecine légale de strasbourg on a
pour règle de couper les cheveux en
quatre
et même de les réduire en poussière pour
détecter les produits dopants crucifix
passé au crible de cette machine
sophistiquée
le résultat est incontestable il s'agit
donc d'un sujet qui utilisent de façon
régulière de l'amphétamine
c'est ensuite à mini caractérisée par ce
que l'on appelle son camp de rétention
nous sommes donc sûrs à 100% qu'il
s'agit d'elle en fidèle et la
concentration mesurés ici et de 3,24
nano grammes par mille cas
ra sont relativement faibles dit
néanmoins signé un usage répété dans
cette année et cette méthode permet de
mettre en évidence de façon infaillible
la quasi totalité des produits dopants
qui figure sur la liste du seuil haut à
l'exception de le p o et de l'hormone de
croissance produits incriminés sur le
tour de france et qui nécessite la
conjonction de plusieurs types
d'analysés en fait il aurait utilisé
deux méthodes complémentaires à partir
de la liste du comité olympique
international a rajouté une abritant
nine pour faire des mesures indirectes
cercle de p o
et puis surtout on utilisait le cheveu
en complément indispensable justement
pour caractériser des expositions
répétées à d'autres produits de quoi
couper court à toutes les rumeurs et
polémiques mais tellement voile l
analyse de cheveux n'est pour l'instant
pas reconnu par les instances sportives
internationales car trop précises
histoire du dopage et du tour de france
n'est pas une nouveauté à vrai dire même
si elle n'avait jamais atteint cette
ampleur car la justice cette fois ci
s'en est mêlée mais ce problème était en
fait un secret de polichinelle les
premiers cas ne remonte pas à hier
malheureusement nous trouve 98 tu
connais la plus grosse affaire de dopage
de son histoire soit pleine de grand
déballage pour crever la pratique disque
depuis 30 ans et le premier contrôle
antidopage a lieu en 1966 et que les
organisateurs avaient destruction de qui
tient longtemps
de plus avant première les soigneurs
planant local séjour ou de recours site
us avec des petites fioles
nous sommes simplement dit sarko qui
marquent et marcel le tanneur après on a
connu ça
7 les contrôles existent depuis un an
dans l'ascension du nouvel onglet tom
simpson très court cette époque les
coureurs prennent des amphétamines
hinson en abuse et meurt d'une crise
cardiaque après le choc provoqué par ce
traitement presque en direct les
contrôles deviennent quotidiens les
coureurs n'auraient pas de se doter pour
autant dans les années 70 ce nouveau
produit atteindrait c'est l'abolition
qui donne plus d'efforts et les
corticoïdes les antidouleurs ils ne
veulent pas s'entraîner les métros entre
dans la conscience des années 70 que si
vous voulez le dopage scientifique c'est
ashton ce qui m'a mis la puce à
l'oreille c'est justement les anomalies
lorsque je conduisais par exemple des
cours
la radio des namas llose évidente il
ironisé l'administration de cortisone ou
l'ours qu'ils avaient des bobos qui
arrive n'est pas cicatrisée et qui était
d'ailleurs un au nord ça j'étais sûr que
c'est que ces coureurs prenaient de la
cortisone dans les années 80 la science
prend son tour corticoïdes anabolisants
sont toujours là la nourrit tes et le
produit masquant des contrôles tomber
passer les coureurs parce qu'au travers
des mailles du filet 1988
pedro delgado gagne au loto de front
pourtant il a été contrôlé positif au
profit d' un produit qui marque des
anabolisants
le produit net reid est alors interdit
par le studio mais pas par les nourrices
internationale belga dont profite de
cette lacune et garde le maillot jaune
s'installe alors une période de succès
les contrôles se multiplient mais la
science du dopage a toujours une
longueur d'avancé 1990 le règne de le
paix aux commandes
le bo augmenter nos bulles rouge donc la
résistance à l'effort
à l'époque lutter ou est indétectable
alors les rumeurs de deux pages prennent
le pas sur les contrôles qui ne sert
plus à grand chose
1991 toute l'équipe néerlandaise pdm
abandonne causes officielles
un jus d'orange à barbier qu'officieuse
mort des 2 h de p o
aujourd'hui on ne peut que constater les
maladies suspecte qui serait dû à la
prise de p o
comment ne pas s'interroger sur le
canter de l'america l'ancien champion du
monde en 94
qu'est ce qu'un bandeau prennent aux log
quentin des risques d'une privé levée de
feo et le développement de tumeurs
comment aussi ne pas avoir des doutes
sur le refus des missions d'opérer nous
aimons après sa chute dans paris-roubaix
l'année dernière les médecins et son sac
une officine au sénat les fatigues celle
occupée aux hormones de croissance des
produits était inconnu du grand public
jusqu'à l'arrestation du soigneur de
l'équipe festina le court et le cyclisme
avec certainement besoin d'un scandale
énorme pour lever l'hypocrisie qui règne
depuis des années alors que les affaires
du tour sont loin d'être terminées on
parle déjà de l'arrivée de nouveaux
produits
criminologue le tour de france à la
rubrique des faits divers inquiète
toutes les sociétés qui finance des
équipes ou qui parraine l'épreuve ce
matin une société hollandaise charme
free qui sponsorise l'équipe tv m a
décidé déjà de se retirer
les autres entreprises pour l'instant
demeure discrète et fidèle au tour de
france mais elle réfléchit sans aucun
doute car le tour de france on
représente une grosse mise des fonds
sébastien guibert patrick rendu
richard virenque stark et l'équipe
festina exclu que laurent jalabert
numéro un mondial qui quittent de
lui-même l'épaule ou encore rodolphe
massie meilleur grimpeur placés en garde
à le tour a perdu ses fenêtres cinq
équipes sur 20 ans qu'il était mais les
sponsors la sur le garnement
même si c'est en a si tu portes le
maillot il sera porté par un autre
véhicule rats l'image que je porte ce
maillot celui de la passion celui qui
était à ce malaise celui qu'a la
compétitivité il faut plutôt penser en
fonction de l'avenir et ce poids loire
steve dean ici dans la tourmente
actuelle pour l'avenir du tour et donc
le gym halle du pin ou l'image du crédit
lyonnais partenaire du tour continuera à
s'améliorer sur l'année à venir
nous sommes persuadés ces sociétés
dépensent beaucoup d'argent pour
profiter de la notoriété du tour de
france un événement qui draine 15
millions de spectateurs sur le bord des
routes et surtout diffusé dans 165 pays
banque assurance enseignes de grande
distribution fabricant de montres de
frites congelées ou de crème solaire
chaque instant une cerise à sa manière
environ 300 mille francs pour ce genre
de caravane publicitaire entre 2 et 20
millions pour soutenir un maillot où une
équipe au total les entreprises
apportent 56 % du budget du tout france
2 et france 3 verse pour leur part 80
millions et les villes étapes et chacune
sept cent cinquante mille francs stentor
télévision commune ne souhaite donc
avoir les preuves s'arrêter et s'il ne
reste aujourd'hui qu'une centaine de
courts
en course plus de 3000 personnes animent
encore la caravane du tour devenu aussi
au fil des ans une gigantesque foire
commerciale ambulante
si les couloirs continue de pédaler
c'est par respect pour le public ni il
un public toujours aussi nombreux sur le
bord de la route qui dans l'ensemble
prend le parti des couacs sont des
passionnés ne se pose tout de même des
questions nathalie moisan de malbec le
tout à retrouver son public enthousiaste
concours agents sur les routes de l'ain
du jura et de suisse par tous n'est pas
nous d'amitié à la grande boucle et sti
rouge aucune manifestation de colère
comme hier bien au contraire
aujourd'hui le spectateur est dans le
conte du coureur avec des coureurs
souhaitant pas ce qu'ils vont faire
comme travail
cette histoire pourtant à changer la
face des 98 pour beaucoup elle a jeté
une ombre sur la course et même un seul
ensemble si fier tous les problèmes
d'argent
cette amertume dati reste le staff du
tour
la caravane publicitaire ses champions
que certains après les événements d'hier
croyait ne jamais voir festif
je suis allé tourner vers l'état pour
demander s'il était passé
je crois qu on compte beaucoup sur un
particulier mais il est l'athlète n'est
pas hyper fière et accueil des
spectateurs suivent l'europe était
connell de réconfort au coeur des
coureurs qu'il choisit d'être inquiet
des troubles
même si les organisateurs du tour ont
répété aujourd'hui encore leur
détermination à terminer l'épreuve
aline la capitale le vainqueur probable
de ce tour 98
l'italien marco pantani aura vu
involontairement son maillot jaune
souillée par toutes ces affaires c'est
déjà ce que l'on ressent un peu dans la
ville dont il est originaire à une
centaine de kilomètres de bologne en
italie sérias josé bové à cesena tiko
sur les bords de l'adriatique on a la
passion du vélo et marco pantani le
champion est ici ça vainqueur du club
italien au printemps dernier
probablement maillot jaune dimanche
prochain sur les champs elysées même les
affaires de dopage ne semble pas ternir
qui a fait la réputation de l'enfant du
pays la serre du dopage ne diminue en
rien le prestige du tour et le protège
les étapes qui devait être faite ont bel
et bien été fait
marco campagne a commencé sa carrière
cycliste à l'âge de 11 ans dans le club
local
il habite toujours à cesena pitot est il
si on le compare déjà au les jambières
faroux stocco en italie la légende ses
fastes aux coqs mais je pense que
pantani a fait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
dans le bar familial tenu par la mère et
la soeur de marco pantani on est
cependant un peu amer vis-à-vis de
toutes les polémiques compte engendré
les affaires de dopage sur le tour de
france c'est sûr que s'il ne s'était pas
passé et qu'on fait avec la police
française mais j'entre à camiers des
petits colis dont le moral était encore
beaucoup prions tous heureusement mais
peu importe à cesena qui comptera une
grande fête à marco pantani le 13 août
prochain
marco pantani celui qu'on appelle ici le
pirate du peloton l'europe impression
similaire dans la petite commune
allemande du champion d'un ulrich tous
ses amis regrette finalement qui n'est
plus allé jusqu'au bout discuter sa
chance contre pantani est in both parker
merdinyan en forêt-noire 2400 habitants
est parmi eux à héros national jan
ullrich qui a détrôné le vin local un
cépage pourtant réputé depuis les
exploits de l'enfant du pays
merdinyan est probablement la commune la
plus chic le fil d'allemagne et nous
petites courses cyclistes aux couleurs
de l'équipe des télécoms figurent au hit
parade des meilleures ventes de gadgets
malgré la tourmente actuelle du tour de
france à saint ferdinand
nous sommes fidèles au tour de france
car nous sommes des passionnés de
cyclisme il faut voir et attendre
maintenant à l'ange l'incontournable
bistrot du village siège du funk la
guyane biche l'intérêt des supporters
pour le tour de france n'a pas faibli
mais l'addiction gagne il sera possible
un très gros préjudice on est de vrais
supporters et pourtant on a du mal à
comprendre il faut évidemment que le
sport est propre et que les sportifs
respectent les règles tout cela est un
peu brutal et très dommageable pour le
trait france et donc en vrais supporters
70 habitants de merian se rendent loin
comme prévu dimanche sur les champs
elysées pour acclamer leurs héros en
johnny ou pas tu étais de ce jeudi c'est
encore de nouvelles tribulations dans la
secte du mandarom installez vous le
savez à castellane dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence cette fois ci
est bien le tribunal correctionnel a
ordonné la destruction dans les trois
mois de la statue géante du messie cosmo
planétaire qui selon les défenseurs de
l'environnement défigurent le paysage
d'insectes a décidé de faire appel de
cette décision
des cinémas farber niveau entre
jésus-christ et bouddha c'est la statue
du mi6 caution planétaire qui domine le
mandat rom 33 mètres de l'eau en honneur
à gilbert bourdin le défunt gourou
baptisé car ses adeptes à manara plus
terre à terre
le tribunal correctionnel de digne a
estimé que cette construction ne
correspondait pas aux permis de
construire et qu'il fallait démolir
colère des adeptes aura pas de facile
s'est scindé uran appel et de toute
façon la pression nationale va être
alertées parce que la presse française
on compte pas dessus mais la justice
française à dix aujourd'hui on sent bien
que ses contrôles et ses mots contre
attaque parce qu'il ya une lecture monde
et comme par hasard on s'attaque à la
seule qui a une valeur symbolique à
leurs yeux puisque c'est celle qui est à
l'éffigie de leur maître spirituel ce
symbole ne sera pas détruit tout de
suite le mandat rom faisant appel mais
pour les écologistes qui ont porté
plainte dont le multiple dossier
l'objectif est d'affaiblir la secte
la seule qui maintenant sommes
aujourd'hui nous paraît contestable
il ya à peu près une dizaine d'adeptes
les journée mondiale de l'eau mise une
16 17 mai qu'a voulu faire donc
amaury vendredi elle a montré face de
l'hommisme ont rapporté qu'une
cinquantaine d'oeuvres sur les milieux
nomi statham et notamment des
informations ont fait état d'un éventuel
déménagement du mandat rom vers le
département du var une rumeur démentie
par les adeptes mais après l'enterrement
controversées de leur chef charismatique
les honey ce supporteront mal de voir
leur emblème redevenir poussière en cas
de démolition
le responsable du camp scout de perros
guirec tu l'abbé cottard déjà mises en
examen pour homicides et blessures
involontaires par manquement délibéré à
la prudence est aujourd'hui également
accusé de non-assistance à personne en
péril
et on a appris aujourd'hui et d'après le
témoignage d'un marin pêcheur que deux
jours avant le drame qui a fait quatre
morts
ces mêmes jeunes scouts avaient déjà été
secourus en mai la demande de
l'opposition parlementaire le projet de
loi sur l'exclusion a été examiné par le
conseil constitutionnel qui a censuré et
plusieurs articles concernant le volet
logement
damien thévenot pierre laurent la loi de
martine aubry sur l'exclusion prévoyait
de taxer dans les grandes villes tous
les logements vacants depuis plus de
deux ans après son passage devant le
conseil constitutionnel
cette disposition a été fortement
assouplies exemple des appartements
vides que le propriétaire n'arrive pas à
louer ou à vendre au prix du marché ne
seront pas taxés pas taxer non plus des
logements qui nécessiterait d'importants
travaux de rénovation pour être
habitable
au bout du compte donc sur deux millions
d'appartements vacants en france seuls
400 me
visé par la loi déception des
associations de mal-logés
les deux propriétaires vont pouvoir
échapper à la taxe sur les logements
vacants alors qu'il ya toujours des
leçons remet santé et 2 millions de
personnes sont mal logées
autre déception pour les associations
les préfets ne seront plus obligés
d'assurer leur hébergement des familles
avant de prononcer une exclusion
c'était pourtant là le souhait du
gouvernement mais le conseil
constitutionnel
on a dit autrement l'autre ambition et
est seulement d'ajouter un peu
d'humanité à la légalité
c'est vrai que nous aurions été
satisfait que ce soit possible dans la
mesure où ça ne l'est pas nous en
prenons acte
mais comme nous avons fait voter un
dispositif qui privilégie la prévention
de l'expulsion nous n'en serons que plus
d'encourager à être très ferme vis-à-vis
de la mobilisation de tous les services
sociaux
le gouvernement compte également
compléter le dispositif dans le cadre
d'une future loi sur l'habitat après
l'échec du rachat de thomson multimédia
par le groupe coréen daewoo du temps du
gouvernement d'alain juppé le ministre
de l'économie et des finances mme
monique strauss kahn ouvre à nouveau le
capital de l'entreprise publique à
hauteur de 30% directeur du groupe
français alcatel mais aussi de
l'américain microsoft
dans un rapport remis au gouvernement le
professeur claude gosling les lacunes du
dispositif actuel mis en place pour
indemniser les victimes de l'amiante
la difficulté principale tourne autour
des critères de reconnaissance des
maladies professionnelles de tous ceux
qui ont une affaire de près ou de loin à
ce produit très dangereux
lowe's et blanc la pierre à nos
questions
cet homme a été officiellement déclaré
inapte attendre de travail l'isolation
des bâtiments touchés gravement poumon
reconnu comme victime de l'amiante
il a pourtant été licenciés quant au
repos aujourd'hui les deux femmes
bénévoles qui est puisque endosser comme
elles le font depuis un an et demi
mon accent d'autres travailleurs
affectés par l'amiante et non
indemnisées s'aperçoit dans le cas de
monsieur yves lainé signe que naît dans
la passe parce que tout a été essayé la
validité la la contestation en matière
de distribution d'une vente maladies
professionnelles la retraite à 50 ans
pour les victimes les plus exposés la
réouverture des dossiers d'anciens près
ce que préconise tout de go dans le
rapport qu'il vient de remettre au
secrétaire d'état à la tactique des
erreurs c'est facile d'aider il y a eu
des erreurs de s'en excuser les
reconnaître mais c'est insuffisant
je pense que la société a une dette
vis-à-vis des gens qui ont été exposés à
l'amiante et qui en sont morts ou qui
est amour
mais pour les atr sont l'intention
d'attaquer vie dans les tontons des
victimes est actuellement les plus
exposés qu'il faut indemniser
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune raison pour
ultime de l'amiante
mal considéré que la société ne le
reconnaissent pas les mêmes droits que
ceux qui sont reconnus pour les victimes
du sang contaminé les accidentés de la
route et bien d'autres catastrophes
sanitaires et pourtant des malades de là
nous rendent compte actuellement et des
musées le gouvernement devrait mettre en
oeuvre de nouvelles propositions
diffusion réduit l'année prochaine
l'urée mans a décidé aujourd'hui un
moratoire de deux ans avant d'autoriser
la mise et vantait sur le marché de
plantes transgéniques qu'angélique
pardon autre que le maïs c'est à dire
essentiellement le colza est elle à
l'etrat la qualité internationale
maintenant après avoir à témoigner
pendant très longtemps le président
américain bill clinton a décidé d'en
finir avec la sphère monica lewinsky qui
affirme avoir eu une relation sexuelle
avec lui qu'il lui aurait peut-être
demandé de dissimuler irvington a décidé
d'accepter de témoigner devant la
justice un témoignage enregistré tout de
même à washington philippe gas le 17
août prochain la déposition du président
bill clinton sera enregistrés sur
cassettes vidéo depuis la maison blanche
le président a pu éviter après d'âpres
négociations de comparaître directement
devant le grand jury
les 23 citoyens chargée d'apprécier le
dossier le transmettrons peut-être au
congrès le président sera assisté par
ses avocats et répondra aux questions de
kenneth starr le procureur désigné par
les adversaires républicains du
président qui le poursuit depuis plus de
cinq ans et puis ne lui fera aucun
cadeau
bill clinton pourra difficilement
changer son système de défense est relié
ce qu'il a juré hambourg moi je n'ai pas
eu de relation sexuelle avec cette femme
avec mademoiselle 2006 molik a dit
exactement le contraire il ya 48 heures
en échange de l'impunité accordée par le
procureur qui goûte tout
elle s'est mise à table non seulement
elle aurait reconnu avoir été la
maîtresse du président mais elle apporte
des preuves tangibles tant espéré par
monsieur star il y aurait des cadeaux
contre autres une robe qui pourrait
recéler des traces qui ne laisse place à
aucune équivoque des communications
téléphoniques pré privé
cela ajouté au pointage des allées et
venues de monica à la maison blanche
parfois des heures tardives des
enregistrements des caméras de
surveillance divers témoignages le
dossier clinton n'est pas bon du tout
cependant 75% des américains pensent
aujourd'hui que si le président a failli
ce qui n'est pas exclu
la faute n'est pas suffisamment grave
pour l'empêcher d'exercer son mandat
mais trois bouclé le rapport de cannes
et ça devrait être transmis au congrès à
majorité républicaine qui appréciera
ensuite ce serait aux sénateurs de
juillet le président américain mais
miracle jusque là quitte à braver
l'opinion publique et à la veille des
élections législatives en novembre
prochain
la question est délicat où dernière
politique en espagne l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur socialiste de josé barioz
nous et vous et son directeur de la
sécurité qu'on a mis à 10 ans de prison
il était accusé de l'assassinât
d'indépendantistes basques espagnols
abattu par des membres du gal une sorte
de police parallèle et qui dans les
années 80 traque est légalement les
séparatistes basques de letea dorothée
nick là clame son innocence mais free
barrionuevo l'ex ministre
l'intérieur vient d'être condamné à dix
mois de prison nous a fallu verra son
bras droit pour la sécurité même
condamnation avec 10 autres accusés
ils ont été reconnus coupables de
détention illégale et malversations de
fonds unique sans leur assentiment a dit
le procureur il n'y avait pas eu légal
les groupes antiterroristes de
libération qui ont attaqué les 28
personnes entre 83 et qu'elle soit
certes le parti socialiste fait bloc
derrière faisant celle des gens qui
clament leur innocence
nous sommes ici en présence d'une
injustice ou une qualité pour les cadors
nous sommes innocents
les escadrons de la mort ajusté
principalement aux pays-bas ce procès il
répondait aux attentats de letea par guy
latry n'a pas eu un mot ce verdict du
procès des galets maintenant le problème
de la responsabilité morale et politique
de l'ancien président du gouvernement
philippe even valait pourtant blanchi
dans cette affaire
en 93 depuis le début de ce procès les
socialistes dénoncent une machine de
guerre politique destinée à détruire le
parti et son ancien dirigeant fort
maintenant 1 2 3 0 l'équipe de france a
gagné la coupe du monde de football
j'espère que ça ne vous a pas échappé
tout va donc pour le mieux pour son
sponsor adidas qui proclamé par tous la
victoire et tendre mais si la victoire
nous avait échappé bien la fiente de
vêtements et de chaussures de sport
avait prévu une position de repli
vincent fourcade bernard complet
je
on les musiques de circonstance il avait
tout prévu nous le dira
même la déclin mais c'est mine allongé
sont restés dans les cartons
le public ne retiendra casse l'otan la
victoire est en nous bloquant risqué
quand la cote des bleus est au plus bas
mais adidas n'est pas numéro 1 il doit
donc choqué quiconque met les voiles
au départ ils ont été très surpris le
cercle bien nous verrons les a surpris
même très peu choqué parce que les
interpellés façon durant 10 anglais il
ya pas ce que vous en êtes exactement
et puis de ses actifs que comme tout le
monde en fait 1 les lensois cette
campagne ils ont commencé à gagner et
tout le monde a suivi derrière la
victoire et pour nous qui devenu un peu
plus qu'un slogan publicitaire
il aimait faire reste les affaires sitôt
la coupe du monde en poche et devant
près de 3 milliards de téléspectateurs
les plus franches disparaît rapidement
sur un tee shirt maison adidas qui me
lie guerre entre les deux géants le
match du camp du camp pour trois
millions de francs par an adidas
s'attacher les services de zidane naïve
s'adjuge ronaldo pour polir le 100
millions de francs l'année
un duel de stars pour lequel adidas 5
entièrement revu sa stratégie
une campagne adidas l'attendait par plus
l'individu l'intériorisation presque
lezennes la victoire et en adidas a
reparlé du football comme si la
tentation se déplace pas positif mais un
ensemble de façon culturelle remarquable
pari gagnant donc les ventes d'autres de
20%
un objectif atteint avant même la finale
la victoire c'est un peu comme un gros
bonus puisque les scènes de liesse et
donc le dernier publicité ferrand
tour du monde le parc national de
port-cros large d'hyères dans le var est
le seul à englober une réserve marine
qui doit donc être protégé on y recense
plus de 180 espèces de poissons et
d'algues sous-marine et tous ces trésors
sont surveillés par des gardes
spécialisé au portage d'un sommet d'
être le responsable scientifique de la
réserve marine de bordeaux
c'est évidemment porter une attention
toute particulière aux murs en quoi sont
symboliques qui avait disparu dans le
nord méditerranéen
il sert et infantile sinon cette zone
protégée des hameçons et déroule en
trois temps de cotisation à doubler les
scientifiques pensent que c'est grâce au
réchauffement de l'eau en méditerranée
que deux jeunes individus c'est à dire
ni femelles sont volonté du sud en effet
le groupe change de sexe et de la mal
causé au cours d'une dizaine d'années
ainsi ce vieux quarantenaire où l'on
sait maintenant qu'il est plus rentable
vivent en paix chez les uns de port cros
on accueille de très nombreux plongeurs
parents chaque année en gros vera à
baham m5000 très facilement mais en même
temps la protection m et une bénéfique
notamment sur place mais également sur
les zones côtières ainsi puisque les
nasri locale profite aux par le jeu des
courants aux autres secteurs qui sont
pas officiellement protégés ce n'est pas
l'une aux interdits
tout la vie sauvage des plaisanciers
c'est le fléau de l'été pour la réserve
césaire nous arracher car les possibles
missions d hervé non les algues sont
autant de blessures infligées à
l'habitat fragile de la faune aquatique
par contre sont de 20 mètres cette
équipe de l'université de nice procès de
recensement cartographier de toute la
ville de logique re la frange du
littoral la zone la plus exposée aux
éventuelles pollutions
un véritable travail de moine leur
botteur des pâtes à pizza est également
certaine époque celle ci la psychose est
l'espèce a dit catherine grâce à des
échanges entre les scientifiques et le
parc national de port cros est resté
cette petite île baignée par une
méditerranée intacte
il craint le plus célèbre ballet moderne
celui du film west side story
le chorégraphe américain jerome robbins
vient de mourir à l'âge de 79 ans
récompensé par deux oscars pour sa
création dans le pays - celle story il
avait auparavant mis en scène des
dizaines de ballet classique il fut
considéré ensuite comme l'un des piliers
de broadway et de ses célèbres comédies
musicales
george d
c'est en 1957 que jerome robbins est à
sec il mentait le congratule sur la
fantastique musique le sommeil
millénaire vers le client sur scène à
broadway avant de battre tous les
records de longévité sur les écrans
cette artiste inclassable qui
s'exprimait aussi bien dans le classique
que music hall a reçu les plus hautes
distinctions américaine du spectacle
oscar et la tds le voici de pétanque
avec new york city ballet qui codirige
est un exemple en chine en 1949 l'année
dernière robin ne cessa de créer quand
le 50 et 70 dans les bacs
j'ai fait beaucoup de parler et je n'ai
kian aient les critères précis dans le
fameux mambo de west side story on
retrouve la gestuelle de la rue et de
broadway intimement mêlée à l'élégance
de la tradition presse
moins connu mais plein de soupe
populaire la chorégraphie d'euros vise
pour le violon sur le toit qui fut jouée
dans les années 60 plus de 3000 poids
une énergie le joie une force à l'image
de la personnalité du monstre sacré de
la danse qui vient de le quitter avant
nous quitter le rappel des principaux
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi le
tour de france qui a repris la route
après les perquisitions
dans bien des cas un bon soir